there are many different ways to put a
shelf of books in order
alphabetically by author or by title by
subject or by the color of the spine
those are all valid approaches for
different situations if you're
running a bookstore that has a lot of
customers coming in and saying oh you
know i don't remember the title but i
know it was red
then sorting by color is a reasonable
approach
in 1876 an american librarian called
melville dewey published a four-page
pamphlet
describing how he thought a public
library should be ordered
before dewey books in many libraries
were ordered by
when they were purchased as new books
arrived they would just be
allotted to a shelf or to a box that
matched their size
and there'd be a central card file
somewhere listing where everything was
you would have to ask a librarian if you
wanted a certain book and
they'd retrieve it for you just browsing
the shelves
wasn't a thing dewey gave each subject
an index number and then said that the
shelves should be ordered
by that number over the years the dewey
decimal system
became a standard dewey had solved a
serious problem how to sort and find
information
without having to bother the head
librarian and because books were
clustered by their subject
it encouraged general interest browsing
of the shelves
uh side note while researching this i
found out
that dewey was a terrible person not in
an
oh but he was of his time where he
resigned
from the american library association
because of sexual harassment complaints
in 1905.
how bad do you have to be in 1905 to get
kicked
his sexist and racist biases made it
into the early versions of the
duodecimal system
lots of libraries these days use
completely different classifications but
yeah we do still remember his name
anyway here's the key point by creating
a useful
index and sorting by it readers could
find books more quickly
that same principle of indexing applies
to computers
and has since the early days
[Music]
there are two basic ways that a computer
can search linear
and binary let's say you've got a stack
of cards they've got numbers on them
that are somewhere between 1 and 50 and
you want to find
lucky number 13. if it's a shuffled
stack then there is
no shortcut you just run through looking
at one card after another after another
after another until eventually
you find number 13. that is linear
search going through
every card in a stack every element in a
list until you find the one or many that
you're looking for
that'll work on any list in any order
but most of the time
it will be slow but what if the cards
are in order
by number sure you have to spend some
time to sort them i've got a whole other
video about that but
once you've done that once they're in
order you can use a binary search
binary not in terms of like zeros and
ones on disk but binary in terms of
splitting things in two
you look at the middle item of the list
is it higher or lower than the number
we're looking for 13.
so in this case it's lower so we can
forget about the first half of the list
and we can do the same again
look in the middle of what's left forget
about the side that we don't want look
in the middle forget about the side we
don't want
and so on and so on and so on until
eventually we find the card we're
looking for or
we know that it's not on the list at all
okay with with 11 cards
binary search doesn't make much
difference but with a million cards
it is lightning fast compared to linear
search
provided that the list is in order but a
stack of cards is a simple example a
database is much more complex
let's say we don't just have numbers on
the cards we also have letters
and let's add some colors as well we
can't sort the cards by
more than one of those properties at a
time so
right now i can use binary search for
number but not for letter
or color in the same way that librarians
can sort their books by title
or author or cover you can only optimize
for one
property at a time for everything else
you've got to run through every book on
the shelf every card in the stack
every item in the list unless you use
indexes now physically rearranging data
on a hard disk
moving the cards around that's called a
clustered index it's like
making sure your dictionary is in
alphabetical order because that's mostly
how you're going to use it
but a non-clustered index is like the
index at the back of a book or a library
catalog it's a separate
store of just the property you're
interested in
stored in a simple easy to access format
if i want to find the card with the
letter k on it
well i can do a binary search through
the index at speed
identify the number of the card and then
use another binary search to go straight
to it
if i want to pull all the green cards
well i can pull just those out of the
color index
note down all those numbers and then
pull just those cards there's no linear
search happening anywhere
again it doesn't make much difference
with 11 cards but with a thousand or a
million or a billion
that's the difference between waiting
hours for a response to your query
and having it in a fraction of a second
of course
each index that you add takes time to
create and space
to store if your computer has ever been
slow because of the indexing service on
windows or spotlight search on mac
that's it taking the time to run through
all your files and
index all the properties that it can so
that when you type something into your
search bar it'll be able to reply as
quickly as possible
but every time you make any change to
your database
if you've added remove or change
something you also have to keep the
indices
indexes whichever up to date so there's
a skill in choosing which properties
which fields in a database you want to
create indices for
if you're only going to search by color
once or twice a year
it might not be worth indexing as with
many things in computer science there is
a trade-off between space
and time now google say that their full
search index is a hundred
petabytes in size and they're
customizing every result from it for
every user
usually in under a second even after all
the changes to google over the years
even after all the space that they've
given over to knowledge boxes and
adverts
even after all the optimization they've
added to give the user
exactly what they want google
still put the time that it took to
answer every
query on every desktop search result
because they're still proud of it
because the logistics and computer
science skills required to do that are
the sort of thing
that phds are written about or because
it's a trade secret the sort of thing
that commands very very high salaries
it's a long long way between dewey and
his decimal system
on the google search result but the
basic principle
create an index is the same
you